[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: [SPEAKING SPANISH]
ISAAC HERNANDEZ:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
YOLANDA LAMILLA:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
JAVIER: [SPEAKING SPANISH]
[APPLAUSE]
YOLANDA LAMILLA:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[APPLAUSE]
SANTIAGO ALARCON:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[APPLAUSE]
ISRAEL OLALLA:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
RAFAEL SANCHEZ:
[APPLAUSE]
ISRAEL OLALLA:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
RAFAEL SANCHEZ:
[BEGIN VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC - "COUNTRY ROADS"]
- OK, Google.
Turn on the hall lights.
- Daddy.
- OK, Google.
Turn up the music.
What's a good
substitute for cardamom?
- Combine one part cinnamon
and one part nutmeg.
- OK, Google.
What sound does a whale make?
[WHALE SOUND]
[CHILD GIGGLES]
- OK, Google.
What's the weather?
- Do babies dream?
- How do you say, nice
to meet you, in Spanish?
- [SPEAKING SPANISH]
- OK, Google.
Dim the downstairs lights.
- Surprise.
[END PLAYBACK]
RAFAEL SANCHEZ:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
ISRAEL OLALLA:
Muchas gracias, Rafa.
[APPLAUSE]
Please let me welcome
Bill Hippenmeyer.
I don't know what to
say as your title.
My boss?
The boss of my boss?
BILL HIPPENMEYER: Big boss.
ISRAEL OLALLA: The Big boss.
Yeah, big boss is good.
ISRAEL OLALLA: He's going to
be talking about collaboration.
[APPLAUSE]
BILL HIPPENMEYER: Hola,
and buenas dias, Madrid.
So it's a great pleasure
for me to be here.
I've recently moved
to Europe from the US,
from Mountain View, to
run our sales engineering,
pre-sales engineering
organization across AMEA.
And we're making huge
investments in this.
Because if we're going to
activate security, secure
applications, and
secure development,
if we're going to bring
artificial intelligence
and machine learning
to the applications
that you're building, we
need to have an engineering
team in AMEA that
you can partner with,
that you can spend
time with and be
able to interact
to be able to build
the next set of applications
on top of this infrastructure.
I want to spend a
couple of minutes
this morning bringing in
another component of the suite
that we have around
Google Cloud.
And the suite that we're
introducing, or actually have
been working on for some time
is our collaboration suite.
And we've had great success.
And you can see by
the numbers, right,
that there are great accolades
for the power of G Suite
and what it's doing
to help organizations
begin to connect, collaborate,
and create the next big idea.
And we can run
through the numbers.
We've been at this for a
little over 10 years now.
I actually have been
here at Google coming up
on 10 years in September.
We have over a billion seven-day
active users over three
of the application areas.
And we have over 3
million customers
that are using these
applications on a daily basis.
But the important question
that I have for you
today is not how successful
it's been in the past.
The most important question is
why has this been successful?
Why are we seeing the
adoption within Google
of these applications?
And what I would
submit to you is
it's all about the
creative process.
I had the opportunity this last
weekend to attend a graduation
ceremony for my
youngest daughter.
So I have five kids.
And my youngest
daughter Kelly recently
graduated from the Savannah
College of Art and Design.
It's in Savannah, Georgia.
It's a school that's dedicated
to the creative arts,
architecture, video-in-motion,
collaboration, fashion--
which is the area that
my daughter graduated in.
And at this graduation ceremony,
the president of the school
stood up and said, in order to
facilitate the next big idea.
If you think about
what you're trying
to do to transform business,
to transform your customers,
to transform the services
that you're providing,
you have to create
that next big idea.
That creation comes
from the ability
to be able to think of new
10x thinking ideas, which
comes from creative
applications and being
able to actually
create to do that.
But what is the synthesis, or
the catalyst, or the beginning
of that creative process?
At Google, we would
argue that the beginning
of that creative
process is engagement.
It's when you sit
around the table,
or in the conference room, or
on a call, or in a video call
and begin to communicate and
interact with those around you,
we start to unlock the
energy of creative.
Right?
We begin to bring
forth those new ideas
and those creative ideas.
In order to do that,
you need a suite
of applications that are going
to support you in that process.
So G Suite is composed of a set
of applications that are really
designed to unlock that
collaboration spirit,
to be able to get people
to communicate together
so that they can come up with
10x new ideas, which you can
then apply to create the
transformations you need
to drive your business forward.
To do that, we think
that there's a problem
that we have to solve.
If I want to be able to
unlock the creative spirits
and be able to
get you to engage,
I have to be able to
solve three problems.
Number one is I have to
build a set of tools that
really focus on team
collaboration, not
individual productivity.
Number two is I have to be able
to clear space in the calendar
by making you more
effective and more efficient
so that you can actually
have room to collaborate.
And then number three is I have
to infuse these applications
with the power of artificial
intelligence and machine
learning so that you can begin
to elevate your productivity
and work at new levels so
that you have the ability
to be able to create the next
generation thing using best
practices and principles of
those people that are experts
within the industry,
experts around you,
experts within the
company, and that you're
actually communicating
and collaborating
cross-functionally
within an organization,
within your department, across
departments, across companies,
with distributors,
with suppliers,
and with your customers.
So that's the power of
artificial intelligence.
How do we actually make that
happen within the collaboration
suite?
Let me have-- are
there two examples,
Bill, that you could give me
today that might illustrate
what Google is doing to create
the room in the calendar,
to make me more
effective, and to actually
help me engage as a team?
All right.
So number one is the
content that we're
going to collaborate
on has to be
easy to access, easy to
find, and the ability
to be able to get
together on that.
And in fact, Google
Drive, all right,
is the place where
people are collaborating.
It is the place where
people are putting
their collaborative documents
so that they can find them
easily and be able to share
them across these different
organizations and across
distributors, suppliers,
and customers.
And what we've built
into Google Drive
is this ability to
have quick access.
So quick access is
all about the ability
to be able to find what
you need when you need it,
and to do it quickly so that
you can save that critical time
and spend more time working
in the collaborative area
than finding the documents of
interest that you need to do.
It turns out that over 40% of
the documents that you access
today in Drive are found
through this capability in Quick
Access in Drive, which means
you're spending less time going
through the folder, and the
subfolder, and the subfolder,
and the subfolder
to find content.
The content that you need is
immediately available to you
by a click of a
button, presented
to you in the very beginning
of your access of Drive.
The second thing
that we're working on
is being able to elevate
your productivity.
This is one example
of something we're
doing in Google
Sheets called Explore.
If you haven't used
Explore, I would
encourage you to do that this
afternoon or do that tomorrow.
The concept is this.
Is that unless you are a
sophisticated spreadsheet
user, writing the
formulas required
to be able to do complex
queries is a difficult task.
Why not unlock the power
of artificial intelligence
and speech recognition
to be able to allow you
to simply speak your request?
Show me in the inventory
all of the products
that have been sold across
these different regions
within the last seven days,
and show me the highest ticket
items and the biggest margin.
What if I could simply just
state that as a question?
And then Google Sheets would
then interpret that language
and be able to turn
that into a formula
and be able to allow
you to visualize
that content immediately
without having to actually write
the formula itself.
And then more importantly, we
actually give you the formula
that you can then take and
implement in your sheet
so that the person coming
behind you, the next person
to go look at this content, can
leverage what you've already
done in terms of
investigation, and can take
the power of your thinking,
applied to the spreadsheet,
with a formula built in
already purposed for you to do.
But it's more than just
being able to elevate
your productivity
and be able to allow
you to work more effectively.
It's also about being
able to work as a team.
So today, if you were
to look at the numbers,
there are over
800 million people
that are using Google
Drive every single day.
We're not talking
about registered users.
We're talking about active
engagement with Google Drive.
But we didn't think
that was enough.
Google Drive is a great
platform and a great tool.
But what we realized is
we need to build something
for teams, a collaborative space
where you can go and actually
work with a team, where the
content that you create,
the information
that you exchange,
and the work that you're
doing collaboratively
is available to you immediately.
And when I come in
as a new team member,
the team space is persistent.
Meaning that all the content
that the team has been working
on up to date is available
to me, and no one on the team
has to go and share that
information with me.
It's already available and I
can see what people are doing.
And then if I leave and go
from Project 1 to Project 2,
all the content that I
created stays with the team
in the team space.
And when I go into
the new project,
I can immediately
get information
about what they're working on.
And I can seamlessly move from
team space, to team space,
to team space to be able to
collaborate in real time.
That's great.
That's wonderful.
But that, again, is not enough.
We believe there's more.
If I'm going to
collaborate as a team,
I need to have a
social dimension.
I need to be able
to chat as a team.
So if I create a
collaborative space,
I also want to create a
collaborative talk environment
where instead of
IM-ing to one or two
people or just a small
team, what I can actually do
is collaborate actively
with the entire team
through the new Hangouts
Chat application.
So picture setting up
a series of chat rooms
on different topics,
on different projects,
on different initiatives
within your organization,
and then being able
to go into that
and have persistence
over the conversation
and be able to
seamlessly integrate
all the content that's in Drive
with the conversations that
are happening about
the content in Drive.
So now just being able to
interact and collaborate
actively is something that
we're bringing in Hangouts Chat.
And then to complement
that, we also
need to bring you a
meeting, a video meeting
product that is going to meet
the demands of the enterprise
use case.
So being able to have the
ability to click a button
and be able to initiate a
Hangout, a video collaboration
amongst peers,
and collaborators,
and partners instantaneously
is one dimension of it.
But it's all the other
things that you've
wanted for some time
in the Hangout product
that are enterprise ready.
So the ability to have,
for example, a one click
access to where, when
I create a meeting,
we automatically create
a conference bridge.
We automatically can sense that
if I'm in a low bandwidth area
using my mobile
phone, that I don't
have to worry about connecting
through the video Hangout,
but I can actually be
connected via a phone.
Being able to record a session
so that I can persist it
for later.
How many times have you
gone into a session where
you've been working
with people, but there's
somebody who's on holiday?
Or there's somebody who
is sick and can't make it
into the office?
But they don't want to lose
the context of the dialogue.
They want to be able to
continue the conversation.
So being able to record
the Hangout, we believe,
is an important
dimension to this.
There are many additional
features that I don't have time
to talk about, but we believe
that Hangout Meet, right,
is the ability to be able
to collaborate video.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[BEGIN VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- You're on Google and you're
enjoying the collaboration
products-- mail,
calendar, contacts.
However, you also have this
need for business process
to be automated.
- Our agency, they don't have
the money to do a full-fledged
app.
They just need something simple
that makes their life easier.
Right now, we have
the Blue Form,
because it's a blue
sheet of paper.
- The Wyoming Flexible
Benefits Enrollment Plan.
- You're filling it
out and signing it,
and then they have
to data entry all
that back in, 10,000
people, a lot of blue trees.
- We were able to make
this in App Maker.
- We showed it to
our HR department,
and they were so excited.
- Honestly, at first
I was very skeptical.
It just seemed too easy,
like, oh yeah, I drag and drop
a couple little things.
What do I care?
I'm a real developer.
I don't use these
little gadgets.
But as I got to use the tool
more, I was like wow, you know,
this really can do
some pretty cool stuff.
- I was able to develop a
relatively sophisticated app
for login monitoring.
From ideation all the way
through the final delivered app
to our administrators for
them to use was five weeks.
And that's just unheard
of in any other kind
of product lifecycle.
- Why App Maker?
Because not everyone is me.
I really like working deep down
in the code, working low level.
The great thing
about App Maker is
you don't need to have
that deep down knowledge.
People were are able to make
these really snazzy looking
applications that can be
used by an entire company.
- I never pictured myself
developing anything.
App Maker is an insanely awesome
way to solve a small problem.
- App Maker makes my
job easier because I
don't need multiple tools.
I can just develop it
directly on App Maker.
- One word to
describe App Maker?
Simple.
- Quick.
- Flexible.
- Versatile.
- Empowerment.
- One word to describe
App Maker, game changer.
[END PLAYBACK]
BILL HIPPENMEYER: So as part
of a collaboration platform,
it's not enough just
to be able to infuse
machine learning and
artificial intelligence
to be able to allow you to work
and create the space you need.
You also need a
platform that allows
you to develop new
applications on top of,
that's simple to use, easy
to be able to program,
and does not require a lot
of deep code experience
to be able to do that.
So Google is committed, as
part of our overall platform,
to providing you a development
environment, as well
as a set of APIs, to be able to
do the back office integrations
and to be able to
drive new collaborative
experiences on top of a platform
that is built for connecting
people and being
able to leverage
the capabilities that we have.
So not only do we have App Maker
as the environment with which
you can build
applications, but we also
are releasing a set of
APIs through the Sheets
API and the Slides APIs,
which are the first ones
to come to market, as
well as the ability
to be able to build
applications that
integrate with the other
components of the platform.
So being able to do
things like Gmail add-ons,
where how many times have
you been in an email--
you know, we use email
every day for our to-do box.
We use email to be able to
trigger the actions we're
going to take.
Why not be able to
integrate the back office
into that experience
through the use of add-ons?
So perhaps maybe
I have a CRM tool,
and a customer sends me an
email about a particular ticket.
Why can't I just launch the CRM
tool directly from the email,
integrate it into
that experience,
be able to go and
use the CRM tool
to be able to solve the
problem, look up the customer,
figure out what's going on, and
then be put back into the Gmail
workflow to be able to respond
with information from that CRM
system, in context, so they can
have a useful flow of activity
going through that?
So the idea here is
that we are bringing
to market a set of
tools and capabilities
that allow you to create
those transformative outcomes.
You do that by
creating 10x ideas.
From those 10x ideas,
the beginning of that
is really the creative process.
And the creative process
is catalyzed and fueled
by your ability to
connect and collaborate.
So what we'd like to
do next is I'd like
to bring up the next speaker.
Virginia Mateos, from GSS,
is one of our customers
who's actively using
the collaboration
suite in their work to be
able to realize the benefits
that we've talked to today.
So with that, Virginia?
[MUSIC PLAYING]
VIRGINIA MATEOS: Gracias.
Thanks so much, Bill.
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[APPLAUSE]
BILL HIPPENMEYER: Thank you.
Thank you so much.
I really appreciate it.
That was awesome.
VIRGINIA MATEOS: You're welcome.
BILL HIPPENMEYER: So we've
talked about the importance
of security.
We've brought home the
power of intelligence
in the platform, and
scalability, and elasticity.
And we've talked a little
bit about collaboration
and the power of collaboration
on bringing those new ideas
to market.
The last piece that we
want to discuss today
is the concept around open.
Why is it important to build
and have an open platform?
Why, if you're going to
invest, do you demand and do
you need to have the vendors
that you work with support,
promote, and bring to
market new open standards
so that you can
avoid vendor lock in?
With that, I'd like to introduce
one of my prize sales engineers
from Berlin, who is a native
Madrid and Spanish speaker,
to talk a little
bit about what we're
doing in the open
area and open source.
Thank you.
Nacho.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
NACHO COLOMA: Thank you, Bill.
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
SERGIO ALVAREZ:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[APPLAUSE]
JORGE NOGALES:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
ALBERTO GARCIA:
JORGE NOGALES:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
ALBERTO GARCIA:
JORGE NOGALES:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
IGNACIO VALILLA:
JORGE NOGALES:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
IGNACIO VALILLA:
JORGE NOGALES:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
IGNACIO VALILLA:
JORGE NOGALES:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
GONZALO DE LA VEGA:
JORGE NOGALES:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
GONZALO DE LA VEGA:
JORGE NOGALES:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
GONZALO DE LA VEGA:
JORGE NOGALES:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
GONZALO DE LA VEGA:
JORGE NOGALES:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
GONZALO DE LA VEGA:
JORGE NOGALES:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]